waking up Terry good morning honey oh
what the hell are you doing it's holding
Amy's last day so we're having a final
heist it's Heist day couldn't you just
send an email nope this was the only way
I have to go alert the others
out it's ice day Rosa sorry about your
milk gotta go
Nico
time stay Charles where's Nicolas he's
crying in the closet gotta go
babe what are you doing
I was hiding so I could surprise you but
if you're here then who's in our shower
it's me Captain Holt it's Heist JJ oh
foreign
I bought him off but he got my key
what's the key for each of us had one
and you needed all four to open the safe
and what's in the safe the 21 million
Bing pots nope I was gonna say Bingo but
then I was like jackpot's better but
then it was too late I was halfway
through the word Bing bot works it's
taken off second
[Music]
come here come here
[Music]
Santiago I know that you hate Halloween
but stick with me and I promise you you
will love it can you magically make
everyone kind sober and fully dressed
kind sober and fully dressed good news
everyone we found the name of Santiago
sex tape
so
you're leaving
it must have been a hard decision
honestly
it wasn't it's funny on my first day
here I asked Jeffers to tell me about
everyone told me you were a great
detective but the one thing you couldn't
figure out was how to grow up
well
I think you finally figured it out
well thank you sir I couldn't have done
it without you over the years you've
sometimes referred to me as something of
a father figure did I I didn't realize
that but I want you to know if I had had
a son
and uh it turned out like you
I would be very proud of them
thank you sir
wow
I wasn't expecting to get this emotional
it's not bad for an old robot huh
you need more sleep
sir did you just make a joke I believe I
did yes I guess in the end we rubbed off
on each other quite a bit
title of your sex movie
did I do that right
it was perfect
you're getting a lot of trouble for this
big secret about Captain Holt is
that I have a flare for the dramatic
look behind you Madeline
we're actually in front of you that's my
fault I thought the layout was going to
be different didn't know how you guys
were going to be sitting I took a chance
before I came to the 99 I was rotting
away behind a desk in the public
relations department all I wanted was
the chance to do good police work again
I just got it and I blew it thinking
about that devil toad
I'm tired of politics
let's get that punk Bledsoe this is
amazing of course we have no idea where
he is but I love where your head's at he
has no family maybe there was a
girlfriend or someone he worked with at
the coffee shop the coffee shop why
would someone who knows they have 21
million dollars coming take a minimum
wage job because he needed access to
that building because that's where the
money's hidden all right we gotta get
there quick maybe we should take the
chopper
death blade
Sidewinder it's go time Roger that wet
blanket no from now on call me
velvet Thunder
oh
okay all right fine take Bob with you
into the Panic Room Rose and I will find
another way out I'm sure you will son
be son no take backs
How Will I Know to open the door when
you hear me knock the Funky Cold Medina
I don't know what the Funky Cold Medina
is even kinda exclude the film you'll
know it's me
we have more than enough evidence to
take you and figures down you've been
played Bob it was all a roost you don't
work with Jake Peralta for three years
without knowing what the Funky Cold
Medina is oh hell yeah ask the guy why
you so fly he said Funky Cold Medina
Funky Cold Medina zero rehearsal
so what's our strategy here I'm thinking
maybe we could do the whole thing in
character I'll play detective Bart
barley tightly wound hates violence
against animals and you're my partner
Gerald James a man who solved every
crime but won the murder of his wife
we're all to take this seriously I am as
seriously as you're taking the search
for the man who killed Jane James your
only clue he wore a yellow sweater
you're considering it let's get in there
shut up mom I'll talk to ma like that
don't you tell me what to do Louie
excuse me
my wife was murdered by a man in a
yellow sweater
it's the one case I can't solve
don't fight with family it can all go
away so quickly
sign this I'm afraid you both have the
mumps mom's still a funny word
are we gonna die
so you both have the mumps sorry to say
it's very contagious
you may not want to be her detective oh
it's cool I keep up to date on all my
vaccinations I'm immune to stuff you've
never even heard of but not immune to
braggadocio
anyhow over the next several hours you
will more than likely to develop fever
aching fatigue doesn't sound too bad
also tart foods will cause intense jaw
pain so you may want to avoid sour
candies what you may get painful way to
like swelling in your neck and often
extreme testicular discomfort
okay hope you guys are hungry made baked
ziti
thought it would be fun to use
Garibaldi's Ultra authentic recipe oh
great pity food thank you anyway but I
can cook for myself wow I would roll my
eyes so hard right now if it didn't make
my brain burn okay Captain this ends now
I know your pride is hurt but no one
ever took pity on you all we wanted to
do was help you when you were down
because that's what people do when they
care about each other they tell each
other lies and invent urgent Mysteries
that need to be solved come up with
excuses to spend time together like
trivia nights or folk art festivals
working old ass cases with their monkey
boy Jake back to you Amy we're doing
great you're gonna eat the Ziti and
you're gonna appreciate it and you're
gonna grow the hell up
okay
you're right
I'm sorry for the way I acted
I can't wait to eat your food
oh it is revolting Wow have you learned
nothing
oh God
that's worse than the mumps Amy I told
you not to lie what were you thinking I
thought it would work and I wanted to be
the one that got him is this about your
ego are you that desperate for everyone
to know how great you are it's not about
everyone okay it's just
I wanted you to know
oh my God
[Music]
he's not answering any questions that's
okay I have no questions that's right
I'm about to monologue son better make
it quick you only got eight minutes all
right then let me paint you a picture
I'm Philip a successful periodontist
that's become addicted to diazepam a
sedative I take because I'm junkie scum
also for real addiction is a disease I
would be super empathetic if you hadn't
murdered a man what is the point of this
I'll get there so one day I'm working
late when my boss Robert surprises me he
found out I was stealing meds again
Chucky's gum also again not your fault
there's a major genetic component to
addiction he says he's going to file a
police report I could lose my license we
fight and something in me just snaps so
I grab the first thing I can find and I
hit him with it you still have no murder
weapon I do now here's a pic I found on
Yelp of the surgical Suite six months
ago and here's a shot that our crime
scene photographer took up the same room
two weeks after the murder notice any
differences we're not answering that
that's all right I can just tell you
myself the Yelp shot has six of these
heavy Looking Glass awards from the
Brooklyn periodontics Society in the
background whereas this shot only has
five what happened to number six you
murdered Robert with him you lost all
control and you bludgeoned him to death
there must have been blood everywhere
but you lucky you were in the surgical
Suite it can be sterilized you never
would have gotten away with it in your
carpeted office that's not what happened
don't say anything more and your office
manager would have heard all of the
screaming but she was at her grandson's
play lucky again you're wrong you put
Robert's body into a wheelchair and
shoved it in the elevator it's a miracle
there wasn't blood everywhere that's not
true now you're in the garage with a
corpse you panicked and left your phone
in your office and you don't have your
car keys but Roberts are in his pocket
so you put him in his car and you take
off you can't believe what you've done
no you're flustered you have no GPS so
you just start driving no next thing you
know you're in the Pine Barrens and it
hits you your uncle's cabin he has a
place there you're the luckiest son yes
it was you got lucky at every turn I
knew exactly where I was driving I left
my phone in the office on purpose I was
in a surgical Suite by Design and I
didn't use some glass award that any
idiot would clearly see what's missing I
made a rod out of a special dental
polymer killed him with it then melted
it back down it's already in a patient's
mouth son
oh damn oh damn oh damn and that is 3-0
dams
oh damn